you know a puzzle is something that
could be solved maybe I can't solve it
because I'm not as smart as you but a
mystery might not be solvable and I
wonder do you make a distinction between
Mysteries versus puzzles well in a sense
puzzles aspire to be mystery that's the
way good puzzles aspire to be like
Mysteries that's not quite solvable but
gives you an inspiration to new ideas so
I view puzzles always like that but I
think for example in the book I talk
about the Enigma of quantum mechanic I
still view it as a mysterious features
that we encounter even though we think
we understand Quantum mechanic features
of experimentation within quantum
mechanics are serious still to me and so
in that sense I agree we haven't solved
it or it's not solvable at this point it
might continue to be mysterious or maybe
it gets resolved in a different form
similar things happen like black holes
we have similar enigmas like Cola
mysteries about black hole
foreign